you went to vcon yeah I went there to go
uh film a video it's bizarre how what
yeah I talked to you yeah yeah yeah I
talked with Gary about it online but it
started once he it was named V Khan to
me that was a it seemed a little
it made me kind of wonder what's going
on what am I getting involved it was
it's exactly picture of econ right now
that's it whatever you're thinking about
what are you thinking about
uh
uh yeah like people bothering people
about money yeah it was a lot of like
bright colors and people who may have
not seen a tit in a while oh yeah I mean
look Gary's a very nice guy and he like
fires these people to [__] up the
funniest thing he said we watched his
speech on the last night and we walked
in at a random part and I walked in on
him going [__] your grandparents yeah
and I'm like that's the energy I need in
life like they are past R.I.P I love you
both but like [__] them you know like
that's just where he's at in life yeah
he and I I like uh oh I mean I totally
respect
I respect his Acumen you know yeah I
think but he also like but he tells
people crazy [__] he'll be like you know
oh you gotta uh
like there's videos of him like meeting
a guy in a park and the guys like I sold
all of our silverware I sold yeah my
baby high chairs I sold everything I
made I made 720 you know it carries like
he like hugs and he's like that's great
the guy's like yeah we're not staying
we're living in this park we're cutting
down all costs and then it pans out and
him and his family are living in a
[__] park right yeah yeah and then
Gary's like you're doing wonderful kicks
it over and he goes That's from me to
you you got to start from the bottom to
be at the top and you were too humble he
talks like uh just like like a crazy
person in front of a 7-Eleven but he's
so convincing at it right like if you
walk past it got yourself let me like
[__] your grandparents you'd be like
sure right I get that yeah but then you
get one of those tiny headsets like the
little like Ted Talk ones and I'm like
yeah you know what [__] him yeah I agree
he makes a lot of good points but yeah
it's just good stuff well I think it's
you all there's always people that are
giving like guidance and inspiring
people inspiring is nice because I think
it's hard to get inspired and so if
garyvee inspires you or whoever you find
that inspires you you know
um that's great no and he he was very
good at it he could say anything and you
put like enough of an emphasis or like
an exclamation point every a book a
couple words in your hand yeah the guy's
like are you are you still using
silverware he'll ask him are you still
using silver like I was a guy and he's
like you can sell you could sell those
you could easily sell those silverware
and be up 25 28 exactly you know yeah
you have to put food in your mouth with
your hand yeah you ever seen the videos
of him going to garage sales they're the
funniest things insane dude he I mean
he's almost he has like 150 million to
his name but he'll go to a garage sale
and be like how much for this ficus tree
and they're like oh seven dollars and he
goes I'll give you four and they're like
oh well I mean
okay we really need it we just need a
liver transplant by Tuesday right it'll
do that and then he'll walk away and I'm
like [__] got him those are still
it's it's hilarious that was I made a
video about this because that's why we
got connected really um yeah I made a
video kind of just talking [__] how he
like literally just low balls poor
families in like Des Moines yeah
like he like hardballs them like he'll
walk up and like 100 bucks for this and
I'm like let me play hard to get goes
his car rips some K walks back and he's
like we'll do 68. okay please our son is
our son has one tooth he's been eating
applesauce out of it too for eight years
and he's like I'll give you three it's
it's electric I love your son yeah I
love that type of energy though good but
he also he was born like with why he was
like from a wine Fortune yeah so that's
the only thing like I'm not knocking it
but it's like
is it always has been has he always had
money like is it really I don't know uh
is it really if you don't have any money
I forget the backstory but I think there
was something where like he like started
the family business or something with
the wine I don't really know what
happened but um
yeah I don't know dude he was convincing
as [__] and it's like you want to laugh
but then you leave there a little fired
up
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one